I am seen at work as a very assertive
and aggressive dude and I seem to rub
people the wrong way when they think I'm
upset or frustrated at problems they
they present which is rarely the case
I'm just so fired up how do I work on my
cat while still being assertive with my
team you know what I'm fired up - how
you like that and when I was young I
this is when I was young sure I rub some
people the wrong way I know that even
when I was a young kid working on a
construction site that's what I was
doing working too hard
making people robbing people when I got
to the team there was a little crew of
us that were too hardcore we were too
fired up we were I would run the Oh
course with my with him with a rock sack
with a 40-pound pack 40 pound sandbag in
it no one was doing that like everyone
does it now but back then there was a
small crew of us that we're doing it
running with jungle boots all the time
instead of in sneakers and I literally
got pulled aside by some of the old guys
and by old guys I don't mean Nam I mean
old guys from wherever you know from the
from the 90s or their late 80s and you
know I'd get the hey just need to call
them down dude yeah you know you need to
do that and so yeah maybe I rub those
guys a little bit the wrong way
understandable but when I got a little
older and a little bit more mature I got
fired up to actually do a good job as a
leader to actually build relationships
with my platoon mates and I got fired up
for people to instead of thinking that I
was upset or frustrated what I was fired
up as I wanted people to think that I
was calm and cool and collected so how's
that for totally different it's like
when we say default aggressive yeah and
I always say hey you're not being
aggressive and dissing being aggressive
towards your people is not yelling it's
being aggressive towards mission I was
I'm aggressive towards making people
think that I'm not upset and that no
matter what's going on - things have man
chocolates he's not gonna lose his
temper he's super level-headed
right now that being said that doesn't
mean that I was passive that doesn't
mean that I wasn't assertive it means
that I was aggressive and assertive but
I did it with tact and instead of coming
to people straight on I flank them I
have listened to their little ideas or I
made their ideas come from me but they
didn't know it I listened to their
solutions I helped and support it well
how do you go so far just by helping
people out and helping them with their
idea instead of trying to control and
make everything your idea so that's my
advice here relax calm down focus get
fired up get aggressive about being
tactful get aggressive about working
with people get aggressive about showing
your calmness that's what you get
aggressive about yeah don't get
assertive aggressive and create
antagonistic relationships across your
company yeah check he said he gets or
they think he gets upset or frustrated
at problems that they present yeah which
is rarely the case he said he said I'm
just fired up so it's it's it seems like
and I'm no expert but I'm trying to put
myself in this position where like I
think maybe like it it's just a
presentation thing you know like well
yeah it definitely is a pretty
irritation is aggressive like he's
saying he's not even getting frustrated
oh I'm getting frustrated with him for
acting this right yeah - yeah it
definitely it's definitely a
presentation thing no doubt about it
yeah but so that means you say okay I'm
presenting the wrong thing I will fix
what I'm presenting yeah do you think
actually I think you do think this or no
this or whatever oh you know how people
they'll they'll get nuts or whatever
they'll they'll they'll be aggressive
they get fired up right and you know
though whether it be they'll lose their
temper or their behave in a
that's that's aggressive towards people
and their justification is not to say
that this guy does this I don't know but
I'm just saying their justification is
I'm just passionate yeah about it I'm
just whatever you know yeah is that
that's just a justification right it is
because yeah yeah like if that's the end
of the day it is it's a it's a
justification it is also a reality so
think about it from the other
perspective if if you're dealing with
something if you have someone on your
team that gets all that they're
passionate about something and it can be
problematic if they don't learn to
control their passions right because
they just get hey we're gonna make this
happen and they make bad decisions
because they're so passionate about
making something happen that they're
done they're not doing something logical
so yes you could say it's just an excuse
and there's no such thing as a
passionate person but that actually
wouldn't be true it's not an excuse it's
a real thing now if you are aware that
then why do you keep acting that way you
gotta put your passions into check
that's what you got to do 100% yeah and
I meant more like it's an excuse for
their behavior you know like to me I
personally I think that being passionate
about something that you're into is good
way beneficial of course but again you
know how to say like there's the
difference between what you feel and how
you behave you know so if you're if
you're super passionate about something
it doesn't justify it like all this
irrational or emotional or like loss of
temper situation behavior you should I'm
saying so you know yeah be passionate
but don't behave in some crazy off the
handle way agree so I think that they
use their passion as an excuse for their
behavior I just got a quick temper man
yeah yeah yeah yeah doesn't mean you can
act like well that's worse that's oh
yeah elbows the same thing same thing
exactly right yeah